bonne nouvelle il y à du travail par ici
on est dans le sud manche qui connaît le
plus faible taux de chômage de normandie
les entreprises manquent de manoeuvre
c'est ce qui a conduit à l'hymne au
teilleul ce n'est pas du tout une
vocation
j'ai commencé par faire un bep sanitaire
et social départ je voulais travailler
avec les enfants
c'était toujours des petits contrats et
là bas tout se débloque en fait j'ai mon
cd
j'ai ma maison en location pour
l'instant mais du coup je peux enfin
envisager l'avenir l'avenir loin de ses
bases elle est originaire du calvados et
rien ne la prédestinait à s'établir par
ici mais c'est chez comme kkl son
entreprise qu'elle a rencontré son
compagnon rencontre d'une citadine et
d'un enfant du pays
c'est un effet de lancement on prenait
un peu le retour à la campagne quitter
un peu les grandes villes est d'avoir
toujours vécu ici bas je me sens bien
j'ai pas du tout envie d'aller tenter
l'expérience en ville on n'a pas enfin
je retournerai pas en ville pouvoir là
non je passe un matin le commerce faut
toujours faire la route les hôpitaux
c'est pareil il faut faire un peu de
route mais bon on va dire c'est le sol
comment par exemple pour l'achat de la
maison je me dis ça se trouve aux mains
avec mon salaire ou le seul à de jean
baptiste on peut envisager peut-être une
belle maison quelque chose que j'aurais
pas eu sur quand enfin quelque chose de
plus plus dans dans mes attentes
ils pourront s'établir au teilleul ou
pourquoi pas à sacyr du bailleul la
voisine sa population ne cesse de fondre
moins de 400 habitants aujourd'hui c'est
la commune la plus agricoles du secteur
est la plus touchée par l'exode au
niveau non des rings tort au kilomètre
carré
oui ça va diviser par 3 4 le relationnel
qui existait entre agriculteurs et
supprimer les gens tellement de boulot
bien plus le temps pour aller discuter
entre eux et en fait c'est un monde qui
meurt dans son coin coin et d'ailleurs
ya plus de jeunes à vouloir s'installer
ça ça devient grave
constat partagé ici à la mairie claudine
sauvé est aussi agricultrice elle
traverse des années difficiles et ne se
fait plus d'illusions sur la réforme
territoriale celle qui intègre saint cyr
à la communauté d'agglomération
mont-saint-michel normandie dont le
siège est à une heure d'ici on a
l'impression qu'elle te sens là on n'est
pas très écoutés nous donne en campagne
y atteler ville qui compte alors
ville le littoral nous on est isolé à
côté de ça on est peu ça s'en va et ça
revient un peu c'est est revenu en tout
cas au début de ce siècle avec la vogue
des néoruraux arrivée d'angleterre et
pas seulement ya le suisse l'a cherchée
et portugaise et lauriane poste
irlandais américain de jambes et un
galop en afrique du sud
la place une ruche
au total une bonne douzaine de
nationalités l'heure de pointe résidents
principaux ou secondaires mais à saint
cyr le sang neuf depuis peu vient du
pays ch'ti ce couple de restaurateurs a
répondu au sos de la mairie les voici en
location gérance pour un tarif des plus
abordables dans cet établissement qui
appartient à la commune et saint cyr
attend d'eux qu'ils remettent sur les
rails
c'est vrai que c'est plus facile quand
on a le passage on allait prendre ville
tout ça autour mais bon moi j'ai grandi
dans un milieu rural comme ici donc ça
me dérange pas ils se renseignent pas
mal tous travaillé à base de projet
normand est aussi l on va travailler
avec les producteurs du village
c'est des jeunes qui sont dynamiques ils
vont vers les gens les gens viennent
vers eux alors je pense que j'espère de
tout coeur que ça va que ça va marcher
elle a rouvert il ya quelques jours la
nouvelle auberge de la source à saint
cyr du bailleul saint cyr c'est bien
connu
ce n'est pas le bout du monde c'est le
coeur du bocage